la pointe de son épée culmine à plus de
100 mètres de haut dans le ciel de Kiev
installez au milieu de la capitale
depuis 1981 en pleine période soviétique
la statue monumentale de la mère patrie
vient de perdre ses premières feuilles
de laurier
les armoires rissoviétiques du monument
vont être démantelés remplacés par le
trident symbole de l'Ukraine dont les
plus vieux emblèmes remontent au 12e
siècle notre
Ukraine a toujours existé et existera
toujours nous allons enlever tous leurs
déchets et construire une nouvelle
Ukraine et nous avons déjà commencé
la guerre impose des décisions que nous
n'avons pas prises pendant longtemps
la guerre impose de prendre ses
responsabilités et de lutter non
seulement sur le champ de bataille
mais aussi sur le fond culturel et
informationnel
cette décision est la dernière d'une
série de mesures prises par l'Ukraine
pour se distancer de Moscou
ces dernières années qui est fait
notamment renommée des rues et des
villes évoquant la période soviétique
vendredi le président volody
mirzuelinski a même promulgué une loi
changeant la date de Noël la fête sera
désormais célébrée le 25 décembre et non
plus le 7 janvier pour ne plus s'aligner
sur le calendrier du Patriarcat de
Moscou le peuple ukrainien a longtemps
été soumis à l'idéologie russe dans
presque tous les domaines de la vie y
compris le calendrier julien et la
célébration de Noël le 7 janvier la
lutte continue est fructueuse pour son
identité contribue à la prise de
conscience et au désir de chaque
ukrainien de vivre sa propre vie avec
ses propres traditions ses propres fêtes
placé sous la tutelle religieuse de la
Russie pendant plusieurs siècles
l’église orthodoxe ukrainienne a été
déclarée autocéphale et indépendante du
Patriarcat de Moscou en 2019